Idol has wrapped there's an open seat
next to Kelly Ripa would you be
interested in taking Michael Strahan job
um I'm sitting there for one day in June
and I can't wait to do that she's asked
me to come on for a date right at the
beginning of june and so I'm looking
forward to hugging her and seeing or not
I've known Kelly forever she's
phenomenal so to get a chance to sit by
her for a day it's a blessing turned
into a permanent gig offer I think that
would be impossible since i have to work
here every day ryan seacrest opened up
to ET at one or two point seven kiss
fm's wango tango on saturday he also
dished on the commencement speech he
delivered on friday antes the return of
american idol last night was a big night
for you you returned to the University
of Georgia and delivered a very special
speech talk to me about that I was
scared to death I was what cuz i wanted
to get it right for the students it was
up all night trying to figure what to
say to them we finally came up with
something i think that i put on paper
that i said hopefully they appreciate it
but it was an honor to do that 50,000
people in the stadium i was really happy
to be there and i got a degree last
night so I'm now graduate fair to call
you dr. Seacrest probably not fair I
don't think anybody would it I think
people would throw stuff at me if I
called myself that but technically you
were a little bit ambiguous about the
ending of idol do you ever foresee it
coming back or I don't know I felt like
that was the thing to say because it
could and it's such a for me it's such a
great show such a part of my life it
could come back in some other forms
somewhere else so never say never ujala
state again I would love to host that
show again yeah job yeah I don't know
I'm gonna do with myself come next
January